this video is brought to you by
liquid IV more on them after the
reaction how's it going citizens of the Reche
Nation we are back with the Adam Sandler voice
because today we're going to watch another classic
from the Adam sander archives it's time for Happy
Gilmore Aaron a thanks for joining me once get
how you doing man you excited that's not Adam
zandler I feel like that Gilbert godfried now
Gilbert godfried here guys we're going to fill
in some more gaps in my Adam Sandler viewing
history once again I did not grow up in an Adam
Sandler house so that's how this happened we did
Dan my boy Tera and I did the water boy and now
we're moving on to Happy Gilmore leave a like
for going back and catching the classics also
subscribe and hit that notification Bell Bell
to get notified the next time an Adam Sandler
movie comes your way and uh hey thanks to the
folks of prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights it is a task and we appreciate them
greatly for it as well if you want to get the
complete Happy Gilmore experience play the whole
18 holes with us along with your own copy that
you'll sync up with come on over to patreon.com
theal rejects we also got a bunch of other movies
and shows over there with reaction highlights
and Wongs included it is a blast my friends
and uh I think that'll do it for the housekeeping
Aaron are you ready I was born ready for born for
[Music]
dler Ha Happy Gilmore my name is Happy Gilmore oh
wow ever since I was old enough to skate I loved
hockey okay wasn't really the greatest skater
though that didn't stop my dad from teaching
me the secret of smacking the greatest Slap Shot
nice Cut nice cut my dad worshiped hockey my mom
didn't that's why she moved to Egypt where there
is not a hockey rink within 1500 miles I like to
think that whoever recorded this home video
made sure to get the face hit in two angles
it's important shot we need it guys he always
said that when I grew up I could be anything
I wanted to but I never wanted to be anything
but a hockey player huh yeah my childhood was
going great but life is full of surprises
Mark mother's B in the music huh all right
whoa everybody be to hit in this own movie after
the funeral I was sent to live with my grandma
wow death by hockey I was kind of nervous since I
really didn't know her that well but she dressed
like the sweetest person in the world what a
grandma after my dad died I developed kind of
a short fuse that kid right there just stole my
party blower and instead of asking for a back
I felt I had to Belt him in the head a bunch of
times with a hammer wow conflict resolution most
of the time I was quick to say I was sorry
a and give a massage not bad High School I
played Junior Hockey and still hold two League
records I was the only guy to ever take off his
skate and try to stab somebody you know that's
that's a hockey game nobody will forget I was a
road worker X you do a janitor yep excellent
yes go for the trifecta perfect gas station
attendant I was going to say downgrade in size
but upgrade and functional wow has a whole ass
been working construction I'm a pretty good
shot with a nail gun uh one day my boss Mr
Larsson waiting for that apparently he also has
a short fuse oh it's it's it's um it's that guy
oh dang anyways those jobs weren't for me
I was put on this planet for one reason to
play hockey ouch don't you ever touch my
P wow how many times this guy tried out
anyway at least 10 times guys's got a lot of
intensity 11 times a charm as they say not a
real strong skater though ain't the best Puck
Handler either hey who leaves Puck handling
out of this talk about the way to handle my
pucks whoa damn is that go regulation size or
what and number 43 the rest of you if your number
wasn't called better luck next year no what about
me I uh called your number didn't I what no you
didn't well better luck next year wow what a
jerk definitely on team now I would love if he
comes out of this like you know what I respect
this we need Someone Like You on the team you
had Moxy kid I went to high school with a guy
worked there so we got extra meatball bye when are
you getting back never she looks so familiar also
she kind of look like drew beore a little bit
thank you to Subway for sponsoring this movie
got to eat fresh hold on a second babe you're
not going for for good are you honey you're
going nowhere happy and you're taking me with you
ouch all you ever talk about about is being a pro
hockey player but you're not any good ouch you
know what you're a lousy kindergarten teacher
I've seen those Finger Paintings you're bring
home and they suck I'm sorry babe I didn't mean
that I I I think they're excellent finger paint
apologize to the kids for me as well I am not
spending the rest of my life with a loser then
get the hell out of my life who needs you beat
it leave me alone I'm sorry why don't you you
just come back upstairs honey I'll give you the
old Smoochy smoo oh oh no you know Happy's
going to make everything okay oh [Applause]
Behave oh God get out of there
kid kiss you all over and over
and again go to him Terry yeah I
didn't expect it to happen damn
get it lady yeah if this was That's
my boy that would have happened oh
100% hey you know why Ah that's my boy that's my
boy well done with the Fruit Loops yeah put that
stuff down that's my grandmother whoa grandmother
hasn't paid her taxes in over a decade wow the
dream I would have but I didn't have any money
she's an old lady I mean look at her she's old
I have no discretion here her stuff is now our
stuff well at least we got the house right no
you don't no I TR to break it to you I have to
take the house too yeah my grandfather built this
house with his bare hands my my grandma's been
here over 60 years this is Gil more owes the IRS
$270,000 and if you can't get the money
together in 90 days we're going to have
to sell the house to someone else yeah me don't
you yeah no no no I don't hate you it's going
to be I just ate this door my grandpa built
with his bare hands you're just the vehicle
in which I had to get my aggression out on the
door yeah hey look at this place silver Acres
Rest Home oh looks more like a country club
than a nursing home looks like a frat house
I'm telling you this place is perfect you're
going to make friends in no time no get me out
of you you tell me how's that nice girlfriend
of yours oh she got hit by a car she's dead in
my heart we're going to get your house back in
the meantime just stay here and and and have
some fun oh B Stiller oh [__] I didn't know
he was in this that's hilarious and I'm sure
he's going to be a totally Savory character
he's very important to me okay extra special
character I'm talking about here I can take
extra special care of that young lady over
there for nothing okay I appreciate that kind
of you but I don't trust you I don't trust it
could I trouble you for a glass of warm milk
you could trouble me for a warm glass of shut
the hell up oh uhoh just getting right to it
check out the name tag you're in my world now
Grandma Hal L son of horel bit I can hit a
ball past that tree 20 bucks as you can how
much you want bet I can throw a football over
the mountains hit a volleyball over to Earth
finish up in there think of it as a way to enjoy
your grandma's possessions for another half hour
wait a minute is that a Will Sasso no it's not
yeah it's Will Sasso is that Will Sasso yeah
oh damn I tell you what you hit a ball past my
ball and we'll go straight back to work that's
totally what Sala I'm not used to not seeing
him with hair yeah it's full headed Hair W
Sasso oh man Vision oh what a lovely fall day
that house is like 400 yards away beginner's
luck 20 bucks says you can't do it again
bring it on oh bring it on also a good
movie great boys are going to pay for that oh that
would have killed him one more time
double or nothing look on will sao's
face oh ow you made a bet pay the
[Music] man wowe dang all right Waterbury
thanks man tell your friends step right up
F see if you can out drive the amazing golf
ball uh Walker guy that's great got it got to
focus on your back swing Carl withs and those
knees remember now it's all in the hips you're
doing great Creed himself all in the hips is
that what Andrew said was it didn't he say
all in the hips all in the hips there you go
look it out Gordon shout out how often do you
play Never this my first time hey you should
play in the Waterberry open tomorrow you're a
damn Prodigy all right I'll see you guys there
ouch he's going to play God he's going to win
yeah buddy shape him mold him Carl Weathers hey
mister you got to wear a helmet don't worry about
it what what the hell oh God I love it oh God
I hurt a little but I'm all right how many kids
tried this 64 more days till next year's hockey
Tri outs I got to tough it up who's your favorite
hockey team comment down below my friend is a
big Habs fan so you're a hockey player huh yeah
you going to give that [__] up you're going to
concentrate on golf a real man's sport you have
no idea who I am dude no I don't back in 1965
Sports Illustrated said I was going to be the
next Arnold Palmer yeah what happened wouldn't let
me play on the pro tour I forgot Arnold Palmer was
a guy I just think about the drink when I see
it what happened somebody else mixed lemonade
with tea first you know alligator bit my hand oh
my God I hooked my ball in the rough down by the
lake damned alligator just popped up cut me
down in my Prime he got me oh my God golf's
no different from hockey requires Talent self-d
discipline golf requires goofy pants and a fat
ass you should talk to my neighbor the accountant
probably a great golf or huge ass you J you win
the open tomorrow you're automatically on the
pro tour then who knows hand this fake an is
killing me you can see him holding it yeah that's
the thing it's like the length of his arm oh of
course of course don't worry about that made
of wood it's real sturdy yeah it's okay it's
okay they probably have a mechanical one now
you got to get him a new hand I thought you
were Pro material Prime to make the big bucks
oh oh you now what kind of big bucks exactly
$270,000 good morning sun isn't this great
blue skies fresh cut gr my God [Music]
no you repaired it hey who's that Shooter
McGavin shooter mavin that's where this
comes from hi I'm Virginia vennett director
of public relations for tour I'm working on
a cross promotional thing right now you know
what would be great if I get a Pepsi a Pepsi
Pepsi I'm a Pepsi girl in a Pepsi World ladies
and gentlemen shooter mavin I've heard so many
people name him as such and never known where it
came from laughed along like of course shooter
mcavin today's big winner will be invited to join
the pro tour and I just want you to know although
only one of you gets to be my colleague all of
you are now my friend I believe that Yep this
guy seems great he seems very genuine has Chris
McDonald ever played like a a Savory character I
don't know laferty Daniel and Gilmore happy
it's a good name happy Gil you one of those
clubs Punk wow Mr Gilmore I'm your caddy oh I'm
sorry about that no no no let me carry these
all right they're my grandfathers are pretty
old what should I do then why you just watch
me and make sure I don't do anything stupid oh
this kid's probably a prodigy himself I can see
that d ouchies with the ball there's no goalie out
there to block it remember it's all in the hip hey
it's all In come on work with me now it's all it's
all in the hip yeah yeah [Laughter] [Music] buddy
hips that's how we get ready for every
reaction oh yeah that's how we warm
ups wowe wow it's like an inverted Evil Dead
shot yeah totally how do they get that shot
anyway I guess by helicopter at this point
it would have to be a helicopter they never
drones back then yeah or they just had
somebody throw a camera yep that's the
most plausible option don't break the wrist
and bring that putter back just like you're
confusing me just let me put the ball in
a hole Yeah aam's razor man the simplest
answer is the best one uhoh this is the
part you're going to have to to refine my
friend you can do the drive but you got
to have the putts man don't want to be a
putts v time and I just couldn't get
the ball in the hole I wanted to but
I just couldn't do it oh yeah wow took a ass shirt
off I'm going to start doing that
to people yeah you got do that
[Applause] [Music] whoop uh damn what the
hell thing of beauty just like curved in
the air yeah man he's bending It Like Beckham
or like Greg Norman comment below who's your
favorite golfer hey the only one I know is
Tiger Woods yep and apparently H Palmer yeah
and Greg Norman he just got a hole in one on a
par he's a publicist dream I mean a guy who can
drive the ball that far you know what else
could dra crowd a golfer with an arm going
out of his ass oh can we get one I to see that he
jelly you a little Jelly Belly oh we in the '90s
this song is baked into my
subconscious pack it up pack
it in let me begin I came to win battle
me that's a s she's like Bart Simpson
H crew climbing the [Applause] ranks was this
the most used song in this era I feel like this
song was in every movie oh yeah feel like it
had to be I always you know the colored golf
balls always seemed like such a cool special
thing to me yes very good very good make this
one in four less shots you win the tournament
four shots just think of it this other team
pull it goalie all you got to do is tap it
in I can do that do it do it like pull oh no
overcorrection but but good Instinct all
you got to do is just tap it in just tap
it in just tap it in a little tappy tap tap
tap tap it tap but tap I'm telling you that's
it happy [Applause]
[Music]
Grandma super oh my God he must had so much fun
that kid oh yeah congratulations I saw that hole
in one on a part four that's got to be some kind
of record huh oh sure sure I skate off and tried
to stab somebody I'm the only guy who ever did
that oh jeez thought we were going to add some
money for this oh well cheer up you next week in
Portland The Winner Takes home $216,000 that's
almost $270,000 this is just as much I need for
Grandma all right so no matter what I'm going to
get some money yeah I'll see you next week then
all right bye byebye she's she's delightful mhm
this is my first trophy only problem is that Goofy
Golf guy on top maybe the guy at the trophy store
if you put a little hockey guy on there who the
hell shut your trap trappy Gilmore happy such a
trappy stop being a damn fool people would kill to
be able to hit the long ball like you you got an
advantage over any man that walks out on the tea
oh you're probably right but I just can't wait I
need money that's spoken like a true [__] look
just no I work with you every day no no no no no
no I I got to I got to go I appreciate everything
tell him why tell him why tell him the truth tell
him the stakes man best of luck kid best of luck
it's okay grief carga tell the return $200 per
quilt yeah well this is handmade quality [__]
we're talking here we're extending arts and crafts
Time by four hours today my fingers hurt well oh
now your back's going to hurt cuz you just pull
Landscaping Duty ouch dude Mr Gilmore how's my
grandma a she's super we're just enjoying some
arts and craft time right now she's in a prison
happy I'm so glad to get me out of here see you
too Grandma I've been thinking about you all the
time Grandma good news I made the professional
golfers tour that's lovely dud you know what
else is lovely if I can figure out a way to beat
those other guys yeah I'm going to get the house
back I can't stand to live in this place another
minute what are you talking about I thought
you like it here well the air conditioner's
broken I'm getting a little warm just let the
kid fix it for you uhoh got the little twisty
knobs oh m m get this off of me oh my
God uh you know that Mista Mista lady
I think I yeah just killed her sure well on your
way the road so far [Music] Sam killing people
hunting things I mean saving people hunting
things the family business Supernatural ER
superal all right I'm Happy Gilmore what's
up yeah happy Mark welcome to oh not even close
looks like Hoffman from saw no I can see it but
it's not it's a nice jacket yeah it is isn't it
it give you one if you win the Tour Championship
hey what's that s of the biggest Tournament of
the Year oh really yeah why don't you join us
at 9:00 on the ninth green what happens there
that's a secret of the pros yeah dress huh oh
all right all right they're going to paddle him
like it's some kind of frat hazing thank you
sir may I have another excellent oh no oh drippy
Gilmore sing Gilmore uh dampened Gilmore gallons
of Gilmore gallons of Gilmore public relations
lady you see shoot him mavin around why I just
need to beat the living piss out of him sh sure
ninth green at nine trick huh it would appear so
now wouldn't it you're right he does deserve
a beating he's just threatened by you he's
worried you're going to steal some of his Thunder
that's nice of you to say steal the Thunder hey my
girlfriend's dead you know she fell off a cliff
and died on impact oh my god get some sleep G
more tomorrow's a big day you're right it is and
you have some unresolved trauma over your dead
girlfriend hello everybody we're going to have a
nice crowd here on this Sensational April morning
22nd annual AT&T invitation Sensational includes
a group of elite golfers from around the world
the favorite has to be shooter maabin are those
dudes like actual sports commentators I remember
well we missed a lot of those in the water boy
I don't know I don't watch golf thanks man hey
he here's my last buck this is the last time I'm
going to tell you a come on he's just trying to
make some money leave him alone a that was nice
he's out here for the people name Happy Gilmore
oh the guy with the long drive hey what's your
Caddy's name H you guys haven't given me one yet
well on the pro tour you provide your own caddy
a all right let me find that kid real quick where
that kid at hey easy with those clubs are right
their antiques hey hey Gary Potter great to have
you on the tour Gary Potter is it always like
this with the uh TV cameras and and the people
and stuff oh yeah a lot of pressure got a harness
in the good energy block out the B sure it's like
a carousel you pay the quarter you get on the
horse it goes up and down around circular circle
with the [Music] music I think I understood I
nope I nope Happy Gilmore all right give me a
club he has socks in
him why is Carl Weathers not here you know he
didn't want him to go compete so soon support
it God whoever's in the booth running
the sensor button is doing a great job on
it you think you can get it that high
definitely I can hit the ball even
higher even harder oh a quar for the boat man
safe passage across the river sticks [Music]
go this guy's gonna have a glow up by the end of
the movie why did he put a quarter there I don't
know it was like an interestingly punctuated
moment unless it's like he was he was doing
some Superstition thing for luck or he was
really giving it to him without giving it to
him there's a reason they call you shoa
[Music] [Applause] mg yeah as most golfers
do you're acting like a damn fool
you need to join the tournament so
you can pay for a new hand go Grandma
Shooter McGavin is putting for the win
maybe it's just me but his crowd seems
unusually small for this type of moment
oh I think most people have found their way
over to Happy Gilmore he's been the talk of
the course today with his huge dve in his
amazingly bizarre behavior happy the ball
itself has its own energy its natural
environment is in the hall so why don't
you send him home send him home bags are packed
he's got his airplane tickets bring him to the
airport send them up metaphors on this guy be
the pilot you know you are go home there ball
gold D it why didn't you just go home that's
your home are you too good for your home they
say you just can't go home you know oh Javelin
wow you almost gored that guy put out a press
release concerning Happy Gilmore being thrown
off the tour I want to see a draft by 6 p.m
you're right but you know but he's so passionate
oh my God I just got a call from the Dallas open
their phones have been ringing off the hook
with people who want to see happy they just
sold out he's chaos he brings excitement to
the game wait money Prophet if he cleans up
his act he can stay if he doesn't it's your ass
any more of this who mother and he's gone you
P what do you think of Happy Gilmore I didn't
get a chance to see him play I was too busy
winning where's my check we'll be mailing them
out next week sir oh no no I want mine now I
don't have any checks to give well that guy
got one right give me one of them big ones I
I don't care that's a commemorative check but
I have always wanted to get one that was quite
a show you put on today Gilmore you were the
talk of the tournament wow thanks a lot you
know you'd be something one of those long drive
contest I'll tell you what I know what you're
doing right now and I don't like it so why don't
you just shut your trap before I put my foot in
it I've worked hard my whole life paid my dues
and now it's Shooter's turn and Shooter's not
about to let his rain at the top be spoiled
by some freak oh I was on this tour for one
reason money but now I got a new reason kick
your ass I'd like to see you try yes oh my God
hey hey what is going on here huh oh I was just
um looking for the other half of this bottle and
uh oh there's some of it right dark why don't you
just put it down yeah I know you'll pay listen to
what I say pay I say bars I can make things out
of clay and lay by the bay I just may what do
you say I can do this all day hey you going to
get dinner or should I pay hey not bad not bad
slay
okay uh uh spray you can have fun but you've got
to keep it within reason all right I will work
on what you call behaving but I ain't going
to act like a stiff out there sportsmanlike
conduct Happy Gilmore makes his way to the tea
in the 72nd annual Cleveland Classic hey Happy
Gilmore Drive 400 yard hey hey he's back it's
that guy uh oh don't be alarmed Mr Gilmore oh
damn he still has the nail in his head oh my God
put the helmet oh my God the nail comes out next
week well you can hardly even notice it Jesu
Chris what is that guy that guy's a Cara how
you take that helmet off without taking
the nail out that's what I want to know I
know [Music] [Applause] right every time with
the shots these like moving swooping shots in
on him it's great he's taking the drives trying
to reach the Green from here shooter that's not
possible sir Happy Gilmore accomplished that feet
no more than an hour ago good for happy Gil oh my
God I feel like the nails making him more
eloquent yeah
buddy hey shooter have a you forgotten your nine
[Music] iron oh my God what a
frame they had to square that
shot up they had to light that
shot I do admire even though half the time
they end up in like pervy rolles Adam Sandler
always be cting like like old people yeah
like older actors and stuff yeah totally
and in this movie his grandma is like super
sweet so yeah hey not bad okay money money
[Applause] money oh my that son of a [__] give
me the ball alligator a well train alligator damn
you've got one eye whoa chubs you took his hand
oh my God it's the gator oh my God oh my God no
[Music]
way damn did he kill it freaking merked an
alligator my God check check one two one two
nice little transition too check four okay
get that money man get that money save your
grandma's house this man is destroying golf
I saw two big fat naked bikers in the woods
off 17 having sex how am I supposed to chip
with that going on Doug you've got to kick
him off the tour he's not breaking any rules
and until he does but he's a disgrace to the
game yeah the sanctity of golf sorry shooter
there's nothing I can do yeah man got to let
the kids have their day like every dog Grandma
I came in ninth place I won 30 $5,000 so we'll
get the house back as long as I don't come in
last place in the next two tournaments we'll
get the money in time yeah you know we should go
on that date I've been pretty good lately well
what is this I hear about you breaking a rake
and throwing it into the woods I didn't break
it I was just testing its durability at least
I didn't punch anybody all right okay we'll go
on a date oh just as friends all right yeah just
as friends slow down friends yeah okay it's play
date get a little time here for Happy Gilmore
anything what happened to this actress I don't
know you used to play Ice Hockey shut up shut
up oh my God power failure did you set this up
no I thought we were going to be just friends
a friends listen to Endless Love in the
dark we are love
she has an a shockness that is very endearing
yeah This song reminds me of seventh grade This
song reminds me of my grandmother she took me
to see this movie I like got the biggest crush
on Brook Shield oh sure what movie well I'm not
going to tell you a true copile would know Aaron
where's Andrew like me yeah where's Andrew he
would know she's stuck in a damn nursing home
the IRS repossessed her house that's why I joined
the tour and I'm pretty close to getting her house
back look don't tell anybody about this I'm I'm
kind of embarrassed uh-oh I'll make you a bet
do you always carry a puck around what the puck
if you get that Puck and nothing that over there
I'll never bother you again if you miss you got to
give me a big fat kiss and she played hockey as a
kid
a talk about your all time
backfires oh uh I see it Go
in okay okay now he's a Happy Gilmore she got
the moves man damn oh my goodness move are you
doing happy I'm Bob Barker wow what a honor nice
to meet you did you get all your pets pregnant
this is a proam happy each golfer is playing
with a celebrity hey you know Nick BDO and I
won this thing last year and I'd like to win
it again this year all right I'll do my best
talking to the right man hey Gilmore Hey Joe FL
you suck yeah jackass no why don't you shut the
hell up what a reaction pun that guy in the face
right now but I can't you know because I'm getting
trouble I bet you got a lot of that on let's
make a deal it's the Price Is Right at uh-oh
let's play some golf okay Joe flarity is hilarious
onv Bob bar alive what the hell what the hell was
that all about it's just that uh you know it's
rainy and that guy and it just it just slipped
come on man don't fail in front of Bob Parker
damn it you will not make this putt you [Music]
jackass nice shooting Soldier who damn all the
way that far down nice and easy and you need Carl
Weathers damn he's getting in his head that guy's
driving me crazy you know what's driving me crazy
you not getting the ball in the hole don't push
me Bob now's not the time maybe it is exactly the
time you that happy GM more anger man wowe this
guy suck damn oh he and Bob Barker are now dead
last Jesus there is no way that you could have
been as bad at hockey as you are at golf wow
you like that old man you want a piece of me I
don't want a piece of you I want the whole thing
oh yeah let's [Laughter] go damn damn let's go Bob
get it Bob get those College boxing days back in
there wow
jeez no the price is wrong
[__] oh my God oh my God no I need the price
is wrong [__] that's amazing this is like a
Family Guy fight I love this or like they live
now you've had enough him waking up is hilarious
[__] [__] that's right bom yeah yeah get
those Jabs get him so I'll see you at the next
tournament right oh no that won't be necessary
this was on national TV Gilmore's gone well look
let's get something to eat there's a Red Lobster
nearby my treat Oh I thought thought we were going
to be friends oh friends we are I just oh Jesus
okay well I'll be at the Red Lobster in case you
change your mind shooter oh he's going to turn
this is not hockey Mr Gilmore no matter how much
you want it to be I know that and I'm sorry
there was some guy out there giving me crap
and it took every ounce of my energy not to hit
him so you decided to headbut Bob Barker oh who
won that fight anyway you'll be fine $25,000
and suspended for one month suspended I got
a play kick him off the tour well the board
thinks that that might be extreme considering
the fact that our ratings were the highest
that we've ever had my grandmother's house
got repossessed if I can't make some prize money
in the next tournament they they could sell it
to somebody else well whoop you do get out wow
consequences man I don't want to hear it it's
over my grandmother's never going to see our
house again Subway eat fresh we're back there
has got to be another way to get the $50,000
I failed okay let me just sit here and enjoy
the one thing that makes me a little bit
happy this fresh delicious turkey filled
cold cut com help keep me strong can I have
one of those coming right up oh my God Jesus
Christ Subway sandwiches will drive away your
hunger was did they really put this commercial
on TV it's a joke ad but it's also a real ad let's
go get your house back comment below gang what's
your favorite sandwich from Subway and spare
no details I want every veggie every sauce put
it in the comments below what the hell hey what's
going on here oh did shooter by the house shooter
bought the house that's going to be so messed
up you said if we get the money by today we
could buy the house back right you can buy the
house back bidding will start at 100,000 100 do
I hear the 100 this is the exciting oh Jesus 275
at 275 new B in the middle under three three now
at 3 350 down front and at 375 oh no at 350,000
down front sold gentleman with the white sweater
yeah shooter probably right yeah a he's the worst
Shooter's the worst you lay another finger on me
I burn the house down and piss on the ashes oh
what do you want for a shoor you off the tour
quit and the house is yours fine I quit oh no he
doesn't happy I need to talk to you oh yeah look
I did this so I could get Grandma's house back
now I can no regrets what do you think grandma
wants more to get her house back or to see her
grandson succeed uh not to be in that nursing
home maybe there's a way she can have both four
championships next week right if I beat you I get
the house back you beat me I'll quit you're going
to beat me the golf oh you're on you're in big
trouble though pal I eat pieces of [__] like
you for breakfast you eat pieces of [__] for
breakfast enjoy your dokos boy [Music] [Laughter]
Doos i f with those poopy Loops no or just regular
raisin brand cereal I was wrong you were right
you're the best I'm the worst let's go crispy
craps frosted shitty
weeds are you ready to get down to
business and do exactly what I tell
you to do believe me I'm ready
then let's get the work right
[__] not I'm breaking the hand
oh my God just buy a new one bro
they've got to have advanced line
up six in in front Okay six Ines ni
oh hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey he's laughing he's having a good time you
going to break those teeth w ah it's rigged the
game's rigged ha that clown easy if you can't
beat the clown how you going to beat Sho mavin
it's going to hit it through the teeth what's
the difference yeah what the hell you're going
to die clown you think funny I don't hear you
laughing now enough what I can't do it sure you
can you just you just did remember now this isn't
hockey you don't play play with raw emotion you
can't putt angry you have to clear your mind of
everything else stay focused is this a real mini
golf course wow now how the hell am I going to
do that think of a place that's really perfect
your own happy place the place you shot grown-ups
at happy place happy place Happy Happ place Happy
my God it's your lady Jesus Christ lady and ler
the ultimate mantasy are those both Michelob
Ultra grandma getting that
money now how do you feel
better now put it's like the opposite of the water
boy yeah hey happy place got something
really special for you here thanks you
see that that is the same putter I used
when I played slightly modified of course
to be like a hockey stick all you got
the spirit of a hockey player in you
happy so I figured why fight well I got
something for you too pal wasn't for you
nonetheless would have happened right so
I wanted to show my appreciation that is
me yeah is it getting longer I feel like that
might be actually true that's a joke I
would put in a movie oh yeah I got his
head did he kill him no [Music] he damn he died
that's crazy no oh my God I don't know how the
hell I'm going to play today just remember
everything that he taught congratulations
murderer his funeral and gamer the same day
you killed a golf legend beat it m oh this is
a memorial you know what I'm going to do I'm
going to dedicate my performance at the Tour
Championship to chub's memory oh you want to
beat him beat him on the course yeah I've got
some very interesting interior design ideas
for Grandma's house bedroom at the top of the
stairs yeah that was my room I think I'm
turning that into my trophy room oh diab
also I I think they had Carl weather's Memorial
like literally here on the green he's just over
there [Music] right damn my God God damn I
wonder if a golf was ever hit it like that
it went like directly in like a I feel like it it
has to right the most legendary uh here's a free
lesson can't learn that in
the hockey R but you can learn
this is it about to go in are you going to get
your wish oh he's closer though after one day
Shooter McGavin is in the lead but the big
surprise is Young Happy Gilmore nipping at
his heels and trailing by only one stroke and
the third day Happy Gilmore has taken the lead
hey Donald it's great to hear from you old cell
phones I need you here in the morning he loves
franchise restaurants happy lead the pack oh
happy is really on today some of the best ball
shots yeah in a movie A1 golf ball especially hard
to get mhm oh my God hit him with a car dude how'
you get a car on the on the field what the hell
what the actual well you okay that was ridiculous
Che oh Jesus Christ what the
hell oh my God just keep off your feet for
a few days to hell with that I got to finish
up yeah baby but I can't believe he's going to
keep playing after being hit by that [Applause]
car oh no my that's the first time he's
failed to out drive Shooter McGavin well
well well Happy Gilmore is Human
After All Human After All death
punk if he's going to have any chance of winning
today he's got to get it done on the green oh
come on now come on now he wants to stay in this
thing he has to calm down and sink some putts he
actually had to like make it do that in camera it
was kind of impressive mhm I wonder how many shots
they had to like redo cuz he actually made go to
a happy place hey different lingerie today is it a
different beer as well oh oh jeez no oh [__] oh
oh no no no no grandma no not Grandma not [Music]
Grandma Cowboy
next no dude these all count as
Strokes nice skip though yeah
oh this looks like the end for
Happy Gilmore shooter now has a commanding lead
oh man always lost dark KN of the Soul what
are we going to do I don't know what to say
I stink I'm not going to win that's all
right sweet the house isn't important
it's just the house stop fraan ising with the
help Gilmore damn I just want you to be happy
darling just be yourself yeah be happy
happy grandma wants me to be happy oh my
get water all in that beer
sh up happy don't feel bad
about me I got my hand back see
and I'm definitely playing this
[Music]
piano I wonder if he actually did it kind of
sounds like it would be him sounds like him yeah
got his mojo back it ain't over yet McGavin
the way I see it we've only just begun we've
only just be we're back [Applause] [Music] baby
let's go get them deep focused long lens shots y
y
heyy it's good putt putt putt in the butt
putt putt in the butt putt putt in the
butt in the [Laughter] [Music] butt let's
do it in the putt okay let's do it in the
putt yeah nice nice and if shooter doesn't
get himself out of this current Funk he's
in he may yet again miss out on the gold
jacket don't Funk with my heart [Music]
yeah that hole in one that hole one oh nice shot
it's okay you can still go birdie
you can go go birdie I know golf
[Applause] terms excuse me I just got to get
through my ball is this boy going to have
the ball oh it struck my foot choice
of words the rule says play it as it
lies o okay nice that's two that's
far shooter oh you can count and
you can count on me waiting for
you and the parking lot oh oh
boy what the doing bro got to get a better
view if he misses happy can t put's way to
Victory d uh yeah I was going to
say Kil more cons it will cap an
amazing comeback oh God I don't
like this oh Jesus I don't like
this dumb oh my God y are all
dumb for that and deserve that oh
great now I have a stinking Tower blocking
my ball we'll get this cleaned up and you'll
finish tomorrow right dog no no he has
to hit it now he has to play the ball
as it lies ouch Brady's right take a shot
Mr Gilmore that guy the commissioner guy
is familiar too hit it around the tower sink
your Putt and we'll go to sudden death yeah
remember your training remember earthquake
remember what you learned I'll just beat him
now good luck yeah go to the happy place
go to the mini golf chubs I know you're
going to help me with this one come on chub
golf golf Subway he fresh coming in clutch
great what do we got
[Music] wow my my guy happy G wins
the gold jacket yep you did it man
well done I love you got his best
gals in his Hobo Jack oh my Jes he
stole my jacket Gil wow oh Christ yes
twirl it on he's trying to put it on
as he runs yeah oh my God great such a
great shot oh my God the pants on that
dude this guy like a wrestler
I feel like he is he has to
be we made it
team he said a whole word the whole movie oh
my God my man's just ready for the high seas
he's on a boat oh Hoy here's the chubs where ever
he is who is that oh my God Abraham Lincoln nice
check who are you waving at happy nobody Grandma
let's go home just the Mount Rushmore of great
spirits the end all right n was fun that was it
was a fun fun and you know what else is fun gang
leaving a five star rating if you're listening to
this on Apple or Spotify that's one of the most
fun things you could do all right reject Nation so
today I want to share something with you that has
been a wonderful addition to my health and fitness
journey that I discovered during the holidays and
that is liquid IVs hydration multiplier I'm
down to my very last packet and I'm freaking
out but it's okay I got more in the ma now a lot
of you have been so kind to notice how I've been
working on my physical health thank you for all
the compliments and one thing I learned is that
proper hydration is absolutely crucial especially
post-workout and pre- filming after post-workout
and my wife actually introduced me to this product
which is perfect because we not only care about
quality but a good taste and quality product
whether it's after a sweaty workout or just
after you know a good night out you know what
I'm saying efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better and it
tastes fantastic I can't emphasize that enough
another thing that I'm always on the lookout for
too is products that have zero sugar or zero sugar
added because that's one of my main dietary
restrictions for the week and they of course
got products that fit that description that also
taste good too so yes thank you so much so liquid
IVs hydration multiplier is in summary is they are
non-GMO electrolyte drink that delivers hydration
into your bloodstream faster and more efficient
than water alone sometimes drinking a whole gallon
is not always efficient but in fact it can
provide the same hydration as drinking two to
three bottles of water I'm also big on efficiency
plus it's packed with 11 essential vitamins and we
know vitamins are good for the body it's vegan soy
free gluten- free and dairy free you can customize
the water amount to your taste again perfect
for post recovery traveling or just having a
big night out you know what I mean noal so if
you want a booster support for the channel and
booster hydration game go to liquid iv.com and use
promo code Rejects at checkout that's liquid i.com
promo code Rejects and remember liquid IV it's not
a real IV sure feels like it so stay hydrated stay
healthy and let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024 wow wow
peacock you don't even let us enjoy the credits
jeez that's another one I've never seen oh my
goodness oh Ricky boobby Ricky Bobby let Greg know
rulas bobus well gang that was fun but uh let's
let's get down to Brass Tack let's talk about
this movie about this Bang movie what you think
man what you think oh man oh man oh man I thought
it was a lot of fun it's a lot of fun to get to
see uh Adam Sandler and his prime you know get to
see this old uh this old golf comedy about this
this hockey player wants to not be a hockey player
who wants to be a hockey player who wants to play
has to play some D golf I got it out got words
do we do we watch the same movie we watch the
same movie he play hockey bad at hockey play golf
now win at golf get Grandma house back you should
be the guy who writes all of the synopsis on like
you know when you pull it up on the streamer and
it's like oh here's a little breakdown I should
yep I'm going to write all of them in caveman as
you've got the it's like if the ones for Rick and
Morty are like that they're just like yo bro this
episode bro is what it is bro they do some crazy
stuff this time bro we got some stuff going on
yeah that's just all the descriptions are but yes
oh yeah I thought I thought it was a lot of fun
you know it was it was it was simple it was 90s
you know like I didn't understand like why this
is a classic movie it was really funny like even
though it came out in what 96 the comedy still
holds up well for the most part and yeah just the
the constant gag with uh with Carl Weathers and
and the uh just there I don't know there was a lot
it was it was really funny seeing uh him and his
prime yeah man that's that's my thoughts as I'm
processing and formulating what you think of the
movie no I agree I mean because this is this uh
I want to say we watched uh that's my boy pretty
recently and then Tera and I also watched H uh
uh the Water Boy and this definitely reminded me
of the water boy in the sense of like this seems
like the sort of Adam Sandler template for this
era in time it's like okay it's a vaguely sort of
sport related thing not to say they were all that
but certainly Adam Sandler has like a vested
interest in sports and then yeah you have like
Underdog with quirky you know qualities for one
reason or another who's going to be mentored by
like a veteran actor in in h water boy it's uh
Henry Winkler here it's Carl Weathers um and you
know like there's a family element of some kind
he's you know either up against or trying to play
for in some capacity relatable there are a lot of
like it's it's fun to see what the tropes of the
Proto Adam Sandler movie are and uh and yeah just
like this I mean I associate Adam Sandler with a
certain amount of like uh you know crude and um
I don't know what you would call it you know like
insult esque humor certainly and this was sort of
uh a little less uh down that path exactly this
was more committed just sort of to the conceit
of what if hockey player but Golf and uh and yeah
like it's got all the straightforward elements
that you would expect from a movie like this just
yeah with his Adam Sandler flavor and even though
again like I didn't grow up with Adam Sandler in
a huge way and I prefer the kinds of roles where
he is more directly committed to a character like
this was nice uh because like water boy is very
much he's playing mannerisms and there is like a
full-on character there whereas this is more like
Adam Sandler kind of being what I associate with
his Vibe and energy more in a general sense um but
I will say that that while sometimes I'm not as uh
drawn towards the ones where I'm like oh Adam s
is just kind of like playing wise cracking Adam
Sandler he playing himself in a sense just like a
heightened version of himself rather than playing
like a character yeah and that's and and he's
feels like he's kind of playing a heightened
version of himself here but I think it it worked
really nicely and I yeah really enjoyed this and
I like that you know I mean my for my personal
taste I'm like you know you you kept the sort
of frat boyishness to a minimum it's endearing
that he's playing for his grandma trying to get
the house back and stuff like that and there
are enough like extra you know uh peripheral
hij Jinks that are happening but it's not as like
insane as it could be and I think that's kind of a
nice thing like this had the right amount of focus
because especially as like comedies have grown and
these sports-based comedies like uh peacock
is throwing us tallad nights to watch right
after this and certainly that was sort of like the
decade later iteration of the sports comedy with
a whole different you know kind of energy behind
it but something about those movies that I didn't
feel as much with this movie and I like tallad
andit certainly but you know like that's from that
Jud appau era where you have you know more heavy
uh emphasis on improv and you have these movies
that'll be a bit more loose and a little less
tightly edited and here it was like you can see
these again sort of Proto uh tropes of the Adam
Sandler movie like with Joe flare popping up in a
role that I assume Rob Schneider would eventually
be the kind of go-to person to have you know the
dude popping up out of the woods not going you
can do it he's sabotaging him here but you know
like there there are fun little uh nuggets and
things and yeah like the way his movies approach
casting and the way they approach like having
the romantic interest and even here like you
know it's it's obviously you can roll your eyes
at the fantasy of like oh she's in lingerie out
on the lawn with jugs of beer but it's also like
it's so silly and it's obviously kind of knowing
what it is in that regard in in a way that yeah at
least feels self-aware and thus you know picks up
an extra kind of layer of humorousness for me um
so yeah you know for what this was I I had quite
a quite a good time and you know being again
somebody who wasn't you know you know I I there
are aspects of of Adam Sandler's flavor that I am
not always gravitated to and am sometimes repelled
by and this didn't really have that which uh which
was nice you know which I didn't expect it to or
anything like that but yeah this uh it was a lot
of fun yeah yeah I also like the the golf shots
you know every time the ball would go and like the
the thing they did with the camera thought that
was really cool uh yeah had some very memorable
moments like that Bob Barker fight was hilarious
proba the funest thing in the movie for me uh just
everything with car Carl Weathers and his hand was
hilarious and yeah you know like there there's the
love interest which is like obligatory for a movie
like this but like you know inexplicably is just
drawn to and likes him right and it's just how
unhinged he is like you you get it because like oh
this guy's a breath of fresh air you know from the
status quo but also it is like you know from the
second they meet she's just like drinking him in
and and these these you know such endearing smiles
and things like that and uh but you know I guess
here it it it makes a little more sense because
he's still a young buck a young Buckaroo and uh
and you know yeah you get your some of your fun
like comedy cameos like you get Kevin nean and
you get Ben Stiller in a small part which I was
expecting shocked yeah I was expecting maybe some
kind of Greater retribution on that character and
that was a thing that surprised me here was like
oh that the the winning the house you know I just
didn't expect them to structure it the way that
they did where instead of it just being like ah
we need to win the final championship in time to
get the money it's you know having Shooter McGavin
step in and buy the house you know raes the stakes
of yeah the third act I thought it was a good way
to in real time answer that question of like okay
well you know like you know we got the money
when they're doing the auction I was like oh
dang I didn't expect this to start happening here
uh and then movie watch together where Adam sandor
needs to make some money for the third act yeah
no exactly like there is like a formula to these
things and it is interesting to see how it warps
and and and yeah like movies like this where part
of the charm is you know roughly who the troop is
going to be and roughly what the sensibility is
going to be and now it's just like what character
is going to emerge from this and what sport or you
know just Niche interest are they going to make
the focus to give this thing the flavor uh so yeah
like you know and that does remind me of the the
the earlier phase in comedy of what would later
become you know like that Jud Appel ear of like
here's an anchor man here's a a Talladega Knights
here's a semipro here's a Kicking and Screaming
you know just like yeah how can we sort of
modularly plug these talents into you know various
little bubbles of culture this movie walk so those
movies could run sure oh yeah I mean this this
movie definitely laid down the groundwork and then
those movies expanded on it um but yeah you know
and then you had uh Will Sasso in there DJ Jackson
is that guy's name I know I've seen him and stuff
um so yeah like a lot of fun just yeah like little
cameos and and appearances and things like that
and I did appreciate how they peacock today man
move right move on move on watch some else go go
go um but yeah I like too that they put like they
committed to the filming of the golf stuff you
know in both respect in ways that remind me of
the brief moments in life where I've caught golf
broadcast and those kinds of shots of the ball and
everything but then also ramping that up with his
Unique Style and approach and the way they shoot
that with his sort of hockey infused version
of this of you know like okay we're gonna go
into ball vision and every time he takes the big
swing we're going to do a S some sort of kinetic
shot you know uh yeah yeah I don't know this was
this was straightforward in in a lot of ways it's
it's sort of the movie I was expecting but I
yeah I thought it was charming and I thought it
was well assembled well orchestrated for for what
it is you know for the most part yeah nice solid
little seven out of 10 for me I I dug it sure
sure what did you guys rate it leave your thoughts
down below and uh yeah thank you for watching
this video thank you for commenting thank you
for being along with the journey and hey if you
want to see another Adam Sandler classic uh you
know I'm sure there are a few others that we still
haven't seen so leave those down in the comments
as well we appreciate you very much and uh hey
we'll catch you next time much love be [Music]
well